this delegates from Myanmar about to
meet rohingya refugees deemed eligible
to return to the country but many of
those that have come to see are anxious
this woman say she has been put on a
list of people to be repatriated along
with three other members of her family
but none of them gave their consent
they tell us we must agree to repatriate
within the next few days if we don't
agree to leave we will face the
consequence I am scared now
and others say they're also under duress
a person from The Authority told us this
is not your home country
you will have to agree to be repatriated
if you don't comply or agree to return
to Myanmar then we will face serious
consequences
trip is the second by Myanmar delegation
in three months to previous attempts to
repatriate refugees since 2017 have
failed and talks to attempt another have
been suspended since the military staged
the coup in Myanmar in 2021. most
rohingya are skeptical about the latest
initiative if it took them six years to
verify only 1 000 people for
repatriation how long will it take them
to verify more than 700 000 refugees and
how with general election due to be held
next January the Bangladesh government
wants to resolve the refugee crisis soon
one issue raised by the International
Community is any repatriation should be
on a voluntary basis and as such we have
assured them that this will be only on a
voluntary basis
Myanmar is the only Authority that can
verify those who can return and issue
identity cards to them based on evidence
of past residents but most of the 1.2
million rohingya here fled a Crackdown
by myanmar's military in 2017. and the
Junta has been blamed for carrying out
widespread human rights abuses returning
home has major risks they want a
security guarantee and an assurance by
the Myanmar government for the right of
citizenship and to be recognized as
rohingya as an ethnic minority group
Rights group same myanmar's military
regime has done very little to support
rohingya citizenship and from what
people here say also very little to
instill confidence in any wanting to
return home tanvi Chaudhary Al Jazeera
Cox's Bazaar